you know it's so funny I get this
question all the time do you still
remember how it felt to drown it was a
crippling feeling I was suffocating
underwater now I've made it my job to
conquer my fear and to help to get these
kids swim lessons and learn how to
respect the water
[Music]
my name is Colin Jones I was in the
Olympics in 2008 and 2012 and I'd love
to give some lessons Colin Jones is a
four-time Olympic medallist swimmer for
Team USA right after getting the gold
medal in 2008 they put the drowning
rates in front of me and I learned the
70% of African Americans nearly 60% of
Latin Americans nearly 40% of Caucasians
don't Madison so it's a big problem all
over the US I think the reason that you
don't see as many African Americans in
swimming is because there's such a
stigma that black people don't swim and
this is something that needs to be
broken because we are losing children
you're losing adults and it's something
that can be changed by swim lessons
swimming lessons are so important to
kids to me personally because I was well
almost one of those kids and part of
this statistic when Cullen was just five
years old he almost drowned on a water
side at an amusement park they had to
come out and grab me and resuscitate me
because I was underwater for about 30
seconds and I think what's important
about the story is that I was fully
supervised I mean it was that easy and
that quick for me to go underwater that
could have been my last day on this
earth and with that near-death
experience colin has made it his
platform to bring water safety education
to kids from all backgrounds the way
that I'm trying to change my community
is definitely worth working with to make
a splash initiative I knew this is my
way of giving back to sports that it's
giving me so much once you learn how to
swim it's like riding a bike you never
forget so take the time learn how to
surf
[Music]
[Music]